[موسيقى]
في مدينه القامشلي في شمال شرق سوريا يقرع
الاكراد السوريون بقوه طبول الاحتجاج ضد
تركيا خلال مسيره شارك فيها الالاف هؤلاء
المتظاهرون رددوا شعارات معاديه للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ورفعوا صور عدد من
ضحايا ضربات الجويه التركيه التي شنها
سلاح الجو التركي ضد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في شمال سوريا في اطار عمليه
اسميتها المخلب السيف المحتجون استنكروا
ايضا ما وصفوه بالتهديدات المتكرره لانقره
بشن عمليه عسكريه في هذه المناطق
السنا بحاجه لاحد لا لروسيا ولا الولايات
المتحده ولا للمجتمع الدولي ايضا اراده
الشعب الكردي لن تقرر نحن مستعدون ولن
نرحل عن ارضنا التاريخيه
يقولون اننا ارهابيون اين هو الارهاب هل
نحن الارهابون ام اردوغان الذي يحاربنا من
الملكيه الى حلب ويحتل ارضنا
وفيما يحذر الكثير من المتابعين من خطر
ظهور خلايا لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
ريف دير الزور وعجز قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في الحد من تاثيرها تصر تركيا
على اقامه منطقه عازله بعمق 30 كلم داخل
الاراضي السوريه على طول الشريط الحدودي
العمليه التي اسميتها انقر المخلب السيف
تعد الرابحه التي تطلقها انكر ضد الفصائل
الكرديه المسلحه في شمال سوريا وشمالها
الشرقي منذ عام 2016